I mean I've been up I got a couple of
Hillary's under my belt man I know how
to sail 430 hours a move yeah
and I know how to self motivate a lot of
[ __ ] don't self-motivate man
like we like to put the headphones on
yeah like before the big game and listen
to the music yeah what the [ __ ] did you
do when the headphones come off bro it's
you and your own mind right I know how
to do that that's that's the hard part
remember listen to music when you run
never never told you James cheat is that
video I got you might have seen it well
I talked about like running with music
and no what did you say I find it find
the video will play it I might not be
able play it we get this is somebody
else's content I actually uh but I did
during my last pull up record I listened
to you know that song from Rocky one
around 14 when rocky gets knocked down
the corner I'm listening to that two
minutes and 13 seconds long
listen I'll repeat for 17 hours Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas man 17 hours
man I went to such the dark dark evil I
have a picture in my hand the book I was
in a dark I went to I went to a place
man that I'm like I can do anything here
we got a live here for a while oh can I
keep on filling that record like I don't
want to see a pull-up bar again I mean
like I did 67,000 pull us man and I
guess my like I can't I don't wanna see
no pull-up so I'm doing this come hell
or high water man I broke it out it's
just a bit let me hear this thing in its
place
so I never train with you sometimes
there's a reason why I'll do that
the music's not going to always be there
the TV the abstractions all these
external things I'm going to gym right
now with all this Bob losing people
needed to get fired up they needed to
stay motivated and they just stay in the
fight
they need to just go to the gym to do
whatever trying to do what do you do
they have no motivation turtle yourself
how you gonna fire yourself up
what's that flame inside of you that
keeps you going like that keep going
like this
and when you're doing this the whole
time you're doing this you're doing some
of the hardest chin-ups you can do you
got a chain around your neck right the
post folks that are just listening and
you're pulling down on ropes you're
doing chin-ups on it looks like taped up
ropes
yes sir that's what it is yeah those are
grip yeah that's like jiu-jitsu guys do
a lot of those yes I was I spoke to the
University of Alabama and they were in
there you know most you know most these
athletes man they got to get height so
that music is blaring yeah I'm like man
what that [ __ ] comes off and you get
popped in your [ __ ] mouth yeah
headphones are on the sidelines brother
yeah we can save yourself then so that's
that's how I train my mind man i trade
my mark I'm no one get popped in my
mouth man I'm gonna get popped in the
back of an alley one day a man running
around doing what I do and there's would
be no music yeah you better fight you
never figure it out I told you Jamie's
cheating I was telling when I first
started running people said do you run
with music I know run-ins cheating when
you have music on it's cheating you're
cheating you listen to music but now I
listen to music all the time but more
than I listen to music I listen to books
yeah books on tape audiobooks and yours
is like I said it's been the last two
weeks it's been my running partner I
appreciate that man you're supporting
phenomenal man that's phenomenal and
you're doing this kind of independently
right yeah so what I did man is I pissed
off a lot of people I was I so in 2012 I
got an offer from my book for $30,000 I
said you can go [ __ ] yourself you know
what he'll I went through brother so
then everybody was like you know we
don't see a market for a black guy
ultrarunner fat guy who couldn't read
like you know 15 percent of America's
black I want to see me [ __ ] you know
people will buy on your book they think
only black people will buy your book
there's some ignorant people out there
man everybody that follows me is white I
don't have a bike I'd like three black
[ __ ] man he that was just letting
some hurry
was a big fan he's black yeah he's like
he's like an unusual species outside man
like and so I'm sitting walking around
going man you don't even know who like
everybody talk to is white like you know
it's the ignorance of the world and I'm
in these meetings here in this kind of
stuff so now 2018 I get a $300,000 offer
for a first time author
so I'm sitting back you know I'm like my
god man you know I used to make like
[ __ ] $60,000 a year you know this is
the biggest payday yet that's how I
think I took that one second I talk
about the one second decision a lot
about what I went through my life what
I've done and I was like you know what I
struggled so hard in my life I went
through so much that the biggest trophy
I own now is that book the biggest
trophy I don't know it's not the book
itself it's what's in the book mmm it's
what like I don't give a [ __ ] if that
sells one copy
honest to god man like like my what I
did and that's what I hope people
understand your life in the journey you
put yourself through there's no there's
just nothing more than that and that's
all I want people to do is realize that
you have to struggle you have to
struggle the bigger the struggle the
bigger the piece the bigger the
suffering the more piece